la saison estivale 2018 a été un très
grand cru pour le tourisme illinois le
château de versailles a vu sa
fréquentation augmenter de 0 3% depuis
le début de l'année à moins de 40
kilomètres le parc zoologique de thoiry
qui fêtait cette année ses 50 ans a lui
aussi connu un très bel été avec cent
trente six mille visiteurs en deux mois
des gens qui habitent effectivement dans
les yvelines et aux alentours sont venus
parce qu'il faisait beau parce qu'on a
fait parlez-nous avec plein de
nouveautés
voilà les toits raison cette année
france miniature avait misé sur la voix
de l'animateur stéphane bern pour
présenter 12 de ses monuments
historiques
un pari payant plus de 68 mille curieux
ont investi le parc élan courtois sur
juillet août la saison estivale la plus
prolifique depuis 13 ans mais l'afflux
de visiteurs a été variable sur les deux
mois il ya eu des trous d'air on va dire
dans cette fréquentation puisque la
coupe du monde à a été un peu
particulière les français sont arrivés
loin et ont gagné la finale et du coup
les éditeurs sont un peu moins sorti sur
cette période et on a connu également un
petit trou d'air avec la canicule qui a
aussi différé les visites royales votre
site touristique le château de breteuil
a réalisé le deuxième plus bel été de
son histoire une affluence qui devrait
permettre à la structure de dépasser la
barre des 125 mille visiteurs en 2018
des chiffres qui aurait pu exploser si
la région n'avait pas été frappée par la
canicule au mois d'août un jour de
canicule
habituellement on fait entre 200 et 200
personnes sans problème un jour deux
fois trois cent dix ans de 300 mais pas
pour ces journées là mais on a rattrapé
pas mal pour le deuxième période du mois
d'août où on est remonté un peu mais
sans rattraper tout à fait période
caniculaire
enfin trafic de loisirs de saint quentin
divine enregistré une augmentation du
nombre d'entrées de 15% entre le 15
juillet et le 19 août par rapport à
l'année dernière
la saison touristique n'est peut-être
pas encore terminé avec l'été indien qui
se profile dans les yvelines au mois de
septembre